et
une chez nous enfin toutes les it de la
chérie de venir maison l'a pas choisie
parce qu'on aimait musique et la gb
benoît limoges et sa conjointe qui
pensait depuis un bon moment
la pandémie les a convaincus de faire le
saut comme sur ses terres ouvertes moi
j'ai eu un petit bureau somme cela coin
d'auxi d'euros ils ont tourné le dos à
leurs 10 urbaine séduit par les charmes
de rivière-ouelle un petit village de
1000 habitants
à l'entrée du bas saint laurent je
compte mes appels jusque là ils ne sont
pas seuls à avoir suivi l'appel de la
campagne
les ventes de propriétés ont bondi de
25% en 2020 dans le bas saint laurent
on a eu un raz-de-marée de gens de la
ville qui voulait tout acheter ce qu'on
avait ici à rivière-ouelle seulement 23
maisons ont changé de propriétaire
jamais j'aurais cru qu'un facteur par
des milk expliquerait une migration
comme on voit en ce moment mais en fait
assez simple à comprendre les gens
veulent de l'espace le dollar va l'avoir
de la liberté le bas saint laurent
affiche un solde migratoire de 719
personnes c'est impressionnant quand on
pense qu'il ya deux ans encore la région
perdait plus de résidents qu'elle n'en
gagne et on est en train de renverser la
vapeur à tous les niveaux mais sachez
qu'on a beaucoup de rattrapage à faire
et du rattrapage il y en a à faire
particulièrement pour l'accès à internet
haute vitesse qui représente un frein
important à la migration
mais le chantier ne s'arrête pas là la
ministre c'est qu'il ya beaucoup à faire
pour que la tendance ne s'y trompe pas
après la pandémie internet
les cpe des infrastructures routières de
qualité
ça va faire en sorte que les gens avoir
envie de s'établir puis d'y rester
c'est la tranquillité de la campagne et
la forêt puis flou
[Musique]
dans un temps il passe une glace avec un
phoque dessus à rivière-ouelle les
prochaines années s'annoncent
prometteuses si on se fie à l'engouement
suscité par ce nouveau quartier en
développement
il ne reste pas beaucoup de terrain les
quelques 35 terrains qui était en vente
depuis 12 ans boisé de lens ont aussi
profité de l'effet pandémie ce qui
amènera son lot de nouveaux rivelois
peut-être 40 % de gens de la région de
montréal un autre 40 % de la grande
région québec sittler qui vont avoir à
chaque année trois nouvelles
constructions pour quatre nouvelles
constructions l'arrivée de tous ces
nouveaux résidents bouleverse
inévitablement à la vie du village
maintenant cette fois assurée par déjà
là sont bien intégrés la communauté
le maire se réjouit de voir que sa
population se transforme mais il veille
à ce que rivière ouelle ne perde pas son
âme tout repos non plus changé la nation
notre milieu en ayant comme ceux un
grand nombre de nouveaux arrivés assez
fou rire même que tout se passe de façon
redonne benoît limoges lui ne demande
qu'à faire partie de cette communauté
ont un projet d'agrandissement est là on
est au mois de mai prochain avec un
entrepreneur la voix grave et réclame à
kiev
nous on a l'intention de devenir des
véritables citoyens de notre présence
permanente de revenir ici avec
l'agrandissement dont je parlais pour
être confortable envol bienne servette à
québec qui vont avec notre mandat et
civelli riga mach radio canada
rivière-ouelle au bas saint laurent